good morning everyone and welcome
welcome to this session this is our
first overview session for
bioinformatics of infectious diseases
and this session what we want to do is
review the program schedule resources
that we will use in the program and
speak in greater detail about the topics
that we will cover throughout this
program that will last starting from May
4th all the way until June so we are
going to get it started here the purpose
of this program is to introduce you to
some of the tools some of the
bioinformatics tools and datasets and
project ideas and essentially provide
you with an opportunity to develop a
meaningful project where you can apply
some of the bioinformatics analysis
methods to publicly available datasets
and demonstrate your understanding of a
specific topic based on data so I want
to start by just kind of clarifying
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
infectious diseases or disorders that
are caused by organisms other organisms
such as bacteria viruses fungi or
parasites as opposed to let's say
chronic diseases that are related to
changes in the body of the human or the
host and some infectious diseases can be
passed from person to person so that's
why they're called infectious they're
transmitted by insects or other animals
and you may get others by consuming
contaminated food or water being exposed
to organisms in their environment so
many infectious diseases are prevented
by the vaccines and a lot of those cause
an acute reaction which are are treated
by antiviral drugs so in the context of
this program what we want to do is speak
about some of these concepts introduce
you to some of these pathogens the
pathogens are those organisms that cause
disease and these are both viruses and
bacteria we will not really talk about
parasites and
but we'll focus a lot on viruses and
also cover a little bit of bacterial
infectious diseases but we will do this
in the context of bioinformatics so we
will really speak about methods of
analysis for onyx data and we'll talk
about how to analyze this data to get
meaningful results from the analysis I'm
seeing that maybe if anyone is having
any technical issues again please try to
look at your your settings and we will
have a recording later on of the session
that you will be able to review okay so
first of all about myself my name is
Elia Brodsky and the co-founder and CEO
of mine biotech pine biotech was
established with a vision to enhance
human health and well-being by enabling
biological research and discovery with
relevant data software solutions and
support like training that we're doing
now our mission is to simplify
bioinformatics and Advanced Research
through our modular and intuitive multi
element analysis platform powered by
human experience and artificial
intelligence we offer training research
support and big data analytics tools
designed for research and biomedical
discovery and our mission is to support
cutting edge research and solve big data
challenges by making our solutions easy
to use and train those interested to use
them to arrive at sound and reproducible
results I am not the only one that is
organizing these programs so I do want
to say a couple of words about our team
I'm honored to have been working with
people that have much more experience in
this area than myself including some of
the other co-founders and the company
dr. Alfred caliber who comes from a
medical background and has deep
expertise in oncology immunology and
biochemistry of inflammation who has a
long-standing recognition for his
generous support of many international
projects and research activities and one
of these projects is the establishment
of the
by informatics Research Center at the
University of Haifa in Israel and that
cetera is essentially at the core of
what we are doing the director of that
Center is dr. Lena Brodsky and he is the
director starting from 2012 he's an
expert in bioinformatics and
biostatistics and has numerous
publications on bioinformatics and and
over the course of his career has
developed multiple novel algorithmic
approaches to biomedical data analysis
with a focus on big data some of these
tools have been widely used in basic and
translational research in biotechnology
pharmaceutical R&D agricultural projects
and biomedical research but what we will
discuss today is also a result of hard
work by some of the people that we have
here on the left
Julia panov who is an expert by
informatician and has helped prepares
many other materials that we will use
today we TTFN Sookie who is a computer
scientist and leads the development of
the t-bone for platform that we will
utilize throughout the program Mohit
Mazumdar who is in charge of business
development for pond biotech Joshua
Kendal who maintains the educational web
portal that we leverage and beeps our
Biswas who is our online community
manager and support specialist who i'm
sure that you have had the chance to
interact with already so just to make
sure that everybody is aware was with
our great team familiar with their great
team so let's start talking about this
program the program is designed to
provide you with some of the tools and
datasets and introduce you to some of
the concepts related to bioinformatics
of infectious diseases and it will last
from May 4th to May 28th in reality
after that you will have more time to
start working on your own independent
project and that is the important
component of this program is not only to
provide you with information but also
enable you and support you in the design
and the development of a project of your
own that you can try and
apply these tools to a data set that you
have selected and you understand what
might be a meaningful data-driven
project where bioinformatics can play a
critical and important role so let's
talk about first the schedule of the
program and some of the resources that
we will use and I'll talk a little bit
more about how to register if you have
not registered already for all the
different aspects that we are combining
into this program so bioinformatics for
infectious diseases is really focused on
three things we will try to understand
these pathogens and the diseases that
they cause so we'll talk about the
different animal reservoirs hosts and
vectors of disease we'll talk about
viral of solution and replication and
we'll talk about also bacterial
infection so we need to understand those
pathogens we'll talk about some of the
analytical approaches how to detect
viral genomes and next generation
sequencing data how to detect presence
of non host genomes in next-generation
sequencing data in general how do we
understand the specificity of our
analysis so once we determine some kind
of a presence of a known organism how do
we know what we have found how similar
is it to some of the more known
pathogens
we'll talk also about vaccine design
antivirals and antibiotics or how does
the treatment fit into that
understanding and then also we'll talk
about epidemiological trends and drug
resistance so epidemiological trends
might include transmission so how do we
look at transmission from a
bioinformatics standpoint how do we look
at drug resistance or efficacy of
different intervention measures from a
bioinformatics standpoint we'll also
talk about not in general terms but
we'll take curated projects and datasets
and we'll actually we have prepared a
number of these that I'll cover in a
little greater detail throughout this
session but they include
epidemic outbreaks that have generated a
lot of data like Ebola zika dengue will
obviously look at corona viruses like
SARS MERS and Koba 19 and we also
prepared a number of materials for
Mycobacterium tuberculosis and leprosy
so we'll talk about some of these so
what's interesting is that there is an
exponential growth of some of these
resources including publicly available
datasets we in fact published a couple
of blog posts recently that talk about
some of the genomics resources for
biology research and education that you
can look on our website right here we
also try to estimate the rate of
submission of genomic data related to
viruses and what we see is at least in
the recent outbreaks including SARS
Ebola MERS Zika and a current kovat 19
we we see a tremendous increase in the
availability of this genomic data that
provides us with a very clear view of
how the pathogen the source of this
pandemic evolves and spreads and so we
can really understand things from a
data-driven perspective in very rapid in
a very rapid way of course what's needed
for that is the experience and the
understanding of the data so that we can
understand where the data is coming from
and how to analyze this data with a good
sense of where to look for what kinds of
patterns and what kinds of specific
changes from whatever we are comparing
this to so I think that training is a
key aspect of being able to to
understand how bioinformatics fits into
this to be able to speak about this as I
mentioned we prepared a number of
resources that we will make that we will
make available throughout
program to the participants of the
program and these are essentially
projects based on public domain data
sets and based on some of the materials
that you would find in a publication so
we actually reproduce some of the
aspects of a publications and analysis
that the authors have submitted we take
elements from that data set ok I see
that some people are having issues with
audio and then if anyone is not being
able to hear
Beechum maybe can you let me know if you
can hear me yes yeah I can hear you
clearly okay great okay well sorry for
those that are not able to hear
excellent Thank You Ryan so we prepared
some of these materials
I think they provide an in-depth and
well characterized data sets that we can
leverage to really understand where to
look in in some of these repositories
and how might we adapt some of those
approaches that we see to a challenge
that we have identified so we we have
here a project on tuberculosis a ultra
deep sequencing called circular
sequencing or server seek of polio
viruses we will look at enterovirus d68
which causes acute flaccid mellitus and
kids and it has been a big public health
concern
recently we'll take a look at the
outbreak of Ebola virus in West Africa
in 2014-2015 and as you know this is
something that is coming back and has
recently emerged again so very important
aspect of infectious diseases and of
course we will dedicate as a significant
time to talking about kovat 19 in the
context of corona viruses in general and
we do
have a lot of these materials that you
can see online to just kind of
understand what that means and here with
this data set we will actually go much
deeper and talk about in greater detail
in a more conclusive way how we can
analyze this data and what can we
understand about this important pathogen
so let me clarify some of the
registration that might be a little bit
confusing for some of you so be trajeron
chad posted a link to this a landing
page where you can pre-register so we
asked you to just fill out a form on
that page and those details come to us
and we try to evaluate that you're a
good fit for this program
so obviously this program has a certain
level that we expect you to be familiar
with some molecular biology terms with
some data analysis terms we feel that
the materials are user-friendly and well
adapted to a beginner but what we have
seen is that some people at maybe
undergraduate or even school level are
interested in joining some of these
programs and we have to make sure that
they do have a sufficient knowledge to
be able to make sufficient progress
during the course of this program so we
do review some your submissions and we
reach out by email and after we reach
out by email what you will probably get
is a link that will ask you to register
on our website and on the website it's a
free registration so you have to create
a username and then you are registered
and you have an account and you can use
that account to access some of the
freely available resources that we
provide there but also you can then
continue to register for the full
program and so in the full program what
you will get is an email and this email
will include the program curriculum and
also a link to the registration right
there so when you're looking to complete
your registration you want to access all
of the sessions of the program make sure
that you click there and when you click
what you will be getting is essentially
a program license the program license
I'll speak about what it includes in
just a moment but the purchase happens
here we do have a discount code a viral
30 that you can use to get a 30 percent
discount from the total price and this
price actually goes to support some of
the activities that I will talk in the
next few minutes okay so maybe if you
could again just please post a link to
the registration page and to the
checkout page so if anyone has any
questions they can take a look at those
links throughout the session and then we
can answer any questions at the end
okay
you
okay so what is the what is this license
include this license provides you with
access to some of the materials that
will be available for the program
participant so you will be able to
leverage those materials to learn about
some of the basic analysis methods so
for example how do we analyze data what
statistical terms what molecular biology
terms do I need to know to be able to go
through some of this material that we're
going to be doing in sessions and also
provides you with a tool so you are if
you're a bioinformatician if you know
how these tools work you will be able to
use those tools however you like to but
the datasets that we will use are large
it's unfeasible to be able to analyze
those quickly on your home computer on a
laptop and so you will be able to access
our platform which is designed for big
data analysis and use that platform to
analyze the data that we discuss in the
class also providing us with a way to
monitor what's going on and provide you
with any kind of feedback that is needed
for you to be able to successfully
complete those pipelines so these things
are separated onto two different links
server T bio info and edu T bio info
that's where the educational materials
are hosted this is the analytical
platform and they are interconnected so
we will talk about this in a second
there's a question here that the
membership expired so the membership
actually starts on May 4th as some
people register before you might have
gotten some email notifications about
your membership expiring however you do
have access for two months so it's going
to be starting in May and all the way
till the end of June and the purpose is
to have access to these materials the
data sets that we have curated and
designed a step-by-step tutorial on how
to reproduce them the analysis that the
authors did but also access to the
platform and that access is a separately
organ so make sure that you add betta
which is marketing at Pine dot bio to
your contact list because she will be
sending you your access information to
the platform okay I will pause for
questions if anyone has any other
specific questions feel free to add that
into the chat but we will pause for
questions
throughout this session so what is the
platform provide us what kinds of tools
are we going to discuss in the context
of this program so one important aspect
of understanding the process of
infectious diseases is being able to
analyze gene and isoform expression
using RNA seek so we will be able to
look at the expression of genes in
response to viral infection or bacterial
infection will be able to understand the
immune response we'll be able to map the
specific gene and Aiza forming level
information on to pathway and gene
ontology level of information but more
than that we'll be also able to use data
mining and network analysis and machine
learning to be able to find those
signals that are going to be integrating
some of the data that we find in these
large data sets so we'll be looking at
that section as well we'll be looking at
for example a project that you see right
here and I'll just play this little demo
this is how the platform looks and works
so this is an example project of
response of different types of cell
lines to different genomes with modified
insertion or deletion of a certain gene
so you can see here that or six which is
one of the poly protein in SARS and
Sarge two produces the or six gene and
you can see here how over the course of
time post infection the cells respond in
very different ways right so you can see
here a mock infection while the type is
the blue and the green is the or six
essentially mutant so this type of
analysis helps
understand how does a certain gene play
a role in the response of a host cell to
the infection by a certain strain of a
virus so we'll talk about some of these
examples now we'll also leverage
mutation variant analysis and we'll look
at a lot of different genomes that have
been publicly made publicly available
but when we have a lot of data one of
the questions is going to be how do we
actually analyze this kind of quantity
of data and how do we make sense of the
most significant mutations that can
explain differences between different
groups of datasets so we'll talk about
some of that data set and we'll talk
about how we can make a meaningful
analysis with the data that we have and
what you see is a pipeline that will
help prepare the data structure the data
so that we can analyze it for
significant mutations now what do I mean
by significant mutations here's an
example right so once we found some of
those significant mutations we need to
understand what impact will it have on
the function of a specific protein that
is produced for example by a gene
encoded in that genomic sequence so
we'll talk a lot about different
proteins organization of the genome into
coding genes or protein coding genes the
function of those proteins the
interaction between those proteins and
how do we understand the significance of
mutations that are going to be important
for us to interpret the data that we
have we'll also talk about evolutionary
study and Association so for example
understand how different genomes are
related to each other or how different
genomic variants are associated with a
phenotype for example in drug resistance
when we talk about tuberculosis how can
we select those specific mutations and
interpret them from that standpoint and
another approach here is multi-omics
integration so if we do have de
on cellular response or host response
how do we then understand how the
different variants and changes in the
genome can be associated with that kind
of again Onix data right so that's where
the key multi-omics
analysis comes from now we have a number
of webinars already on some of the
elements of this kind of analysis but
just to illustrate we will have a number
of comparisons between for examples and
novel coronavirus and previous
coronavirus outbreaks we'll learn how to
perform such analysis but we'll also be
able to link the genomic data to data at
the protein level so what you see here
is a tool that we designed that takes in
the output from the platform that we
just went through and then helps us
understand the position of different
mutations and how can we interpret those
mutations in the context of the proteins
that those specific regions make so
we'll use some of that we'll also use
the same tool to understand the function
of vectors so those are insects for
example mosquitoes that carry the virus
and spread the virus and of course the
virus is under different evolutionary
pressures as it is inside the host for
example human or it is transmitted by a
mosquito and so we'll take a look at how
analysis of data between those different
hosts can help us understand the
response of the virus to some of those
evolutionary pressures beyond that the
platform offers additional tools that we
will not unfortunately have the time to
cover in the program in the training
program but I did want to mention that
it offers mathematical modeling and
viral replication and the process of
infection so once we generate the right
kind of data we really can describe that
data in biological terms how do we
translate that understanding biological
understanding into mathematical terms
and use ordinary differential equations
to prepare a model and then be able to
sin
relate that model to evaluate the
difference the different types of
relationships that we have between
factors affecting that infection and
spread of the virus we will also talk
about some of the other tools that are
available a big part of generating the
right type of data is being able to
analyze microscopy images so we do have
a section dedicated to that and then
obviously screening and docking of 3d
structures is a topic that a lot of
people are thinking about in the context
of in silico drug design or even the
understanding of vaccine design so we'll
talk a little bit about 3d structures
and we'll talk about some of the
strategies for that kind of thinking we
won't really do a lot of hands-on
because we will be focused a lot on the
onyx data first so again as beeps
dimension here SEC nav is a tool that we
developed to be able to visualize a
number of outputs from the platform and
you're welcome to explore and as we go
through the program we will enrich this
specific demo version of the C curve so
that you can explore and interactively
understand how the data looks so just
briefly I will go there so this is the
platform the platform is going to be
available for all the participants the
paid participants of the program if
you're not a pay participant of the
program but you're interested in a demo
this platform we can create a demo
account for you and you can play around
with some of the demo pipelines but we
will also discuss how to then apply some
of these tools to real projects that are
research-based and so we do offer
research licenses for that and just to
illustrate how that works let's quickly
take a look at how we have what you can
learn from using this pipeline so again
a lot of the methods are publicly
available and a lot of the datasets that
we will analyze are also actually all of
the datasets that we will use are
publicly available data set so we want
to be
to reproduce results that have been
published and discussed those in terms
of the data and the analysis that were
able to do ourselves so this is an
example from a major medicine that was
recently published in March that
describes the origins of SARS
Kovan 19 or SARS 2 and here you see a
phylogenetic analysis of different host
genomes and the comparison by looking in
specific regions of that genome so we'll
try to reproduce a similar analysis
where we essentially take those genomic
sequences understand how they can be
aligned to each other so multiple
sequence alignment we'll talk about the
relationship between genomic data at the
nucleotide level and amino acid level
and how those have specific physical
chemical properties that we need to
understand and interpret their function
but also in terms of evolution we'll
talk about the distance between
different codon changes and so when we
talk about that transition from
nucleotide level to amino acid level
what we need to understand is that those
changes are not as simple from an
evolutionary standpoint from one to
another so we will talk about how to
incorporate that into our phylogenetic
analysis we will also talk about
different phylogenetic tree building and
and models and so we'll talk about for
example what is the basic concept of
this evolutionary analysis and how do we
select the right methodology for the
analysis that you're interested to do
and then we will talk about the result
so I'll just briefly show you that some
of the outputs and and why it's
important to talk about the different
results that we see here so including
visual results including results that
are in some kind of a file format that
we can then take to a table manipulation
software or some of the other tools that
you might already have a question here
how
can I get a demo account be sure please
you can share that information with read
me and I'm just going to also
demonstrate the sequence navigator so
once you get that output from the T bio
info platform how can you actually
visualize that data so this is just an
example here where we are looking at for
example different strains of
coronaviruses and we're looking at their
change from a reference genome and
what's important here to understand is
not only accumulation of those mutations
these are bins across the genome but
also the impact on the different
proteins that those sections encode for
and and especially the structure the
structural component of those different
proteins a question from Ryan here does
the platform during pre-processing de
novo support viral classification and
filtering for depletion of numerous mRNA
MIT RNA and non-coding RNA etc so we
will talk about the process of data
preparation so how is viral metagenomic
sequencing what does it mean and and
what exactly happens during that library
preparation step and then how does that
apply to the analysis so we will talk
about that in fact our next session is
going to be on next-generation
sequencing and we will talk about those
different strategies for understanding
how the data was prepared and what are
we expecting to find including some of
those other non-coding RNAs and other
information ok so again you're welcome
to play around with that and if she can
help you set up a demo account if you're
interested ok so we did get two
questions we already answered a couple
of questions but I will pause here for
just a few moments to make sure that if
anyone else has any questions about what
we talked for a few minutes in the
beginning
I'll be happy to answer that right now
so we talked about what the program will
cover in terms of what resources and
what tools and next I will go into the
schedule and we'll talk a little bit
about the schedule we talked about the
process of registration and you have the
links if you have not completed the
registration and also the different
things that you will get access to do we
need minimal computer requirements to
perform the analysis so again all of the
analysis that we will be doing together
will be done on the platform I will talk
a little bit about how the platform is
connected to the educational resources
in other words to the project's the data
sets etc but you do not need any kind of
computational resources on your own so
you can access this from a Chromebook
the only thing that you do need to need
to have is an ability to store and
upload data sets these are going to be
you know tables in Excel so if you're
able to open files in Excel if you have
an ability to download those to your
computer or somewhere that's all you
would need ok how many hours a week will
the program require from our parts in
terms of effort on average that's a very
good question and what I would say is
let's answer this question after we go
through the schedule which is what we
will do next ok but just in general I
would say that a lot of this is up to
you so we hope that you can leverage
this program to develop a project of
your own and be able to complete the
project on your own that's why the
project the sessions of the the program
are scheduled for only one month and
then at the end you given another month
to fully dedicate that time to working
on a problem of your own and hopefully
get to a result if you're not able to do
that or don't want to do that you will
still benefit from doing the online
materials and participating in the
online sessions and yes there will be
certificates given at the end so we'll
talk about that in just a second
okay any other questions so video
lectures yes we will have video lectures
they're going to be interactive lectures
like this today we have participants
that are also not a part of the program
yet and so after we have our group that
everybody's registered what we will do
is we will review process
sorry review progress of participants in
each session address any questions or
challenges that they might have faced
performing the analysis or going through
the materials that we have shared we
will have an interactive Q&A session
just to make sure that everybody
understands the material but a lot of
this is also going to be a synchronous
in other words that the materials could
be completed on your own and we have
some of those materials available and
I'll actually show you a few of them in
a couple of minutes and we will record
the sessions and then we will send you
that recording to all the participants
and the cost is one hundred and fifty
dollars before the discount the discount
is going to end when we start the
program which is going to be Monday so
make sure that if you want to still
register register today or over the
weekend again any questions about
discounts payments how to register it
cetera or we'll be happy to answer that
beep sure we'll be able to handle that
and if you have already enough
bioinformatics background or are
interested to apply the tools to a
research question we're happy to support
that as well okay are there any other
questions or should we move on
okay how can I make the payment again we
will send you the information but we
have some of the links that you can
start from pre-registration and then all
the way to being a part of the
membership so leap so please share that
yes the sessions the the sessions that
are going to happen let me go through
the sessions next and you will see every
one of those sessions does have a time
if you're not able to join during that
time you will get a recording okay and
micao considering the previous
experience of participation and the fact
that your projects are very well
prepared how many projects can be taken
as part of this course during this
course as many as you wish
as you know we work in parallel with the
programs to make sure that materials are
somewhat structured and we hope that you
will be able to navigate those but of
course we're able to answer any
questions that you might have as you go
through the projects as well we estimate
that a project takes at least a few days
to complete the way that it was prepared
but they're designed to have an open
ending so you don't have to just
replicate the analysis that we did we
hope that you will try and do something
additional with a new dataset or
modifying the analysis itself so it's
really up to you we only provide this
for two months
yes again yes in terms of registration
the registration will be expiring at the
end of June so yes so from May 4th until
the end of June June 30th you will have
access to materials and the platform and
the materials that you registered for
throughout the session you will be able
to complete throughout that time ok just
to be clear in the program will we have
access to the platform that by enrolment
we will receive credentials for the
duration exactly yes so for the duration
of the program you will have access to
the platform and and those credentials
will be active meaning that you will be
able to analyze public domain data and
specifically the data that we provide or
data that you find and submit as a
project are all the small courses that
are within the edu web 3 some of them
are free some of them have minimal
prices like $10 and so yes you are
welcome if you're not familiar with
bioinformatics I would recommend
starting with introduction to
bioinformatics if you are familiar with
bioinformatics and I recommend taking
before advanced courses not all the
courses are geared towards infectious
diseases but they could be useful and
we'll talk about that in the next few
slides
and if you're registered for the program
by the way you have access to all of
those courses that we won't discuss here
in the next few minutes okay so let me
go on so that we can make sure that we
cover the schedule of the program so if
once you've registered you will be able
to in fact let me go there you will be
able to see the program and what is
included okay so once you are registered
you will see some of the sessions that
we will discuss next here and you can
register for individual sessions if
you're not interested in the whole
program or you can register for the full
program as well so you can navigate like
this and see some of the coming up
sessions and you can see that they will
end up with all the way into your
independent project so let me also show
you there's a syllabus right here maybe
it's easier to see the overview like
that and it's in the description of each
one of these sessions and I'll talk in
detail about these sessions here in a
few minutes so again we will start on
Monday May 4th and then you can see
throughout the throughout the sessions
what topics are actually going to be
covered so please take a look at this
and so you can see what we plan to cover
so now let me go over this together with
you and answer any questions that you
might have about that so we will start
next session is going to be on
next-generation sequencing so as you
know and as we already discussed these
original sequences of viruses come from
a host and the host has their own
genomic information in them and not all
of the viruses or bacteria inside might
be harmful so we'll talk
little bit about what next generations
and next generation sequencing data
looks like and how do we extract from
their relevant information to study an
infection right so when we have an
infection how do we first find specific
reads that represent that infection that
we're looking for and we'll talk about
different strategies for doing how we
have some library preparation techniques
that can help us amplify specific types
of genomes or we'll talk about how we
just look for everything and then from
everything that we have available
extract whatever we need and what are
some of the analysis methods to do that
the second session is going to be
dedicated to multiple sequence
alignments so once we have identified
some presence of some specific genome
how do we focus on specificity and
understand relationship of what we have
identified to other more characterized
and known genomes that we can understand
by comparison how they are related
whether they come from the same origin
and how are they different and then what
these sessions are designed to do is
just to provide you with a broad
overview and then in the next session
we'll actually have a hands-on session
where we will run multiple analyses
together so before that time you might
play around with a pipeline and really
see how it works but then if you have
any questions or you want to understand
how to find the data upload the data put
it into the platform and then start
comparing the different sequences we
will do that together during the session
and we will focus this session on full
genome so whole genomes that have
already been assembled after that after
you will have some time to play around
with some of those pipelines and
reproduce some of the analysis on your
own or try an analysis of your own we
will talk about how do we analyze the
pipeline results so once we got a result
from a pipeline what do we do next
what types of different file outputs
will we
you're looking at and how do we actually
understand the significance of what we
found Ryan we'll discuss that in the
context of a Q&A session with some
practical examples then we'll start
talking about transmission and infection
spread how do we understand the
relationship between genomic data that
we look at so just from the standpoint
of a genome and the process of infection
that takes place in a single host and a
single patient for example and then all
of a sudden spreads to me and so how
will we look at viral adaptation and
transmission in the context of the
biology of virus and the replication
that it goes through
I will then talk about the disease
progression and outcomes so what are
some of the important features that
characterize differences in the ability
of the virus to enter the cell replicate
within the cell eventually causing the
host to either be very sick and how does
that contribute to the spread of the
virus or potentially die and why is that
maybe a bad thing for the virus as well
and so really we will talk about that
evolutionary relationship between the
host and the pathogen where one needs to
keep replicating using the hosts
resources and the other one needs to
survive and suppress that replication
but both actually change as a result of
that interaction so we'll talk about
that virus host circuitry or virus host
interaction then we'll talk about a
hands-on session so practically speaking
what can we learn from available data
right so a lot of the discussions are
going to be around okay what has been
published what has been known what kinds
of issues are highlighted but then we
need to bring it down to a real data set
right and so we'll take a few data sets
here and we'll talk about the origins
and we'll talk about a pendant
as opposed to an epidemic as opposed to
just a single infection how do we
characterize some of those things by
just looking at data then we'll talk
about the rate of mutation so we'll talk
about different types of mutations and
different ways to characterize mutation
some of them based on knowledge some of
them based on for example what we know
mutation can cause as a change in a
codon and the resulting amino acid or
residue that comes out of that but also
we'll talk about how can we understand
fitness and how can we understand random
as opposed to accumulating beneficial or
detrimental mutation and and what kinds
of datasets do we have to characterize
that kind of difference in data we'll
also talk about how that type of
understanding can lead to effective
strategies in for example vaccine design
or association between the spread and
the danger and the effectivity of a
specific strain and some of the concerns
public health concerns or intervention
concerns that people have and so we'll
talk about some of the protein structure
function I will talk about some of the
examples where you can see here an
important mutation that was used for
understanding the different strains that
were more or less infective how can we
study and generate that kind of data and
how do we analyze that kind of data and
interpret what it actually needs and
then we'll talk about host pathogen
interaction so we do have Onix data from
cellular response or the host response
we do have the genomic variation that we
can observe how do we integrate that
data together and what can we learn
about the process of integration of some
of the some of the challenges that come
out of there right so in two main
strategies the strategy of knowledge
driven and the strategy of kind of
unsupervised or data-driven so we'll
talk about that and then right after
that what we feel by that point is that
you're equipped for doing your own
and you can start working on a project
either before that and still participate
in the sessions that we hold to ask
questions and get support and of course
share your results if you're interested
but also after we complete the sessions
if you want to work with someone else in
the program and collaborate on a project
and and that would be a way to leverage
some of the different skill sets that
people have some have more computational
skills some have more biological
experience and some might be able to
find an interesting data set and be able
to extract all the right information
from the databases that we will discuss
so we'll talk about this in the context
of this session and really we hope to
help you plan the full analysis from
beginning to the end and also introduce
you to ways of effectively finding the
data set and bringing the data set onto
the analysis into the analysis plan so
that you are doing that effectively so
that is the session but also a whole
month that you will have to work on your
independent project to get a sense of
what this these sessions might look like
we recommend that you visit our YouTube
channel and look at some of the recent
recent video recordings of those
sessions that we held at different
universities including Louisiana State
University and Loyola University
Georgetown University and and others
where we you can see the interaction
with the students and some of the
questions that are being posed some of
the datasets that we review all of that
is in the context of Kovan 19 but you
will see how that applies to some of the
other some of the other datasets that we
will discuss again what are those
projects that we started preparing so we
will talk about tuberculosis we'll talk
about
the polio and other Intel viruses will
talk about Intel virus d68 an acute
flaccid man myelitis in kids and will
talk about Ebola but also will dedicate
time to speaking about SARS and cope
with 19 and in the process any of you
can propose a project that might be
interesting to you and we hope to
contribute to the analysis that you'll
do so in the context of each project
will actually take a detailed look at
the meta data that we have available for
the Onix data that we have so here you
can see for example the spread of Ebola
in West Africa and that is an important
component of the genomic data that we
have access to and so in the context of
that same Ebola virus project we'll
review some of the important articles
and publications that came out during
the time of that of that early 2014-2015
outbreak and eventually how the
understanding of what the virus does and
how it interacts with the cell we can
identify specific critical proteins and
how those proteins over time led to the
development of a vaccine and what are
some of the alternative vaccine designs
that have been proposed throughout that
process as well as how do we understand
the immune response and the challenge of
sustained immunity from vaccination
we'll also talk about the interaction
that between a host and the buyers so
again a lot of this is going to be
focused on finding the right data so
we'll go and we'll find the data
together we'll take some extraction from
the full data set that is available to
prepare small exercises that you can
work through fairly quickly in the hopes
that you will be able to go back to the
full dataset and find data that is
interesting to you and develop something
novel so we'll talk about how to
navigate some of these repositories and
how to make sure that you select for the
right combination of elements to make a
good data set for comparison and when we
talk about these smaller examples we'll
actually try to focus on some
reproducible analyses that will have
clear-cut outcomes for you to be able to
make sure that you're doing the right
thing and you're actually getting the
result that is expected from an analysis
right so for example as I mentioned
before how do we compare different
strains of coronaviruses and understand
which one is more related to which one
and how are they different
and then map that kind of difference on
some important element and for example
for vaccine design like the spike
glycoprotein where we see a difference
between different areas with abundant
mutations and how do we interpret what
is the function and we'll try to link
these different levels of information
that we are processing and we are
looking at to be able to make more
interpretable results from the analysis
by using different strategies for
comparison and different types of input
data that will lead to different types
of outcomes so again i'm i hope that the
questions about access to the different
resources the questions about different
sessions that we will have and the sched
and how long you will have access to
different things have been answered
during this session if you have a
question about you know what are these
sessions going to look like and how am I
going to be able to use the tools I
highly recommend again going back to our
YouTube channel and seeing some of the
previous recordings and if you have any
more specific questions I'm happy to
answer those now
and Thank You BJ yes so now in chat you
can see the link to a YouTube channel
where you can see some of the previous
sessions
you
all right great there are no more
questions we're going to start on May
4th that's going to be Monday next week
okay there is a question sorry how can I
get a mentor to start a specific project
okay great so okay first about a mentor
so we will have a group of people you
know 20 to 30 maybe 50 people that will
participate during different sessions
and we will introduce some of the
experts throughout those sessions so we
have some experts on molecular biology
of different viruses that will join some
overview sessions and be able to answer
some questions we will have some
bioinformatics experts that will be able
to talk about analysis methods and help
you with that you do have an opportunity
to interact with our team throughout the
session and communicate with us we will
have a forum dedicated to this program
where all of those questions will be
answered either by us or by somebody
that can answer that question and
hopefully find someone that is going to
be a good match for your project okay
Martin Blazek if I registered for the
course at the edu site should I be able
to login to the server side yes you
should have get an email before Monday
on how to access your account on the
server and if you have not and over the
weekend I'm sure you will but make sure
that you make those you know you pay
attention to those emails because there
will come from by email and you will
have a different login from the edu SEC
will there be an opportunity for
publications with the research gig what
is the interface with our and Python and
Java and sequel so first publication so
obviously the publication is something
that you can do in several ways
typically you might prepare a poster and
may be submitted to a conference you
might do a full publication on some meta
analysis right or if you have access to
some novel data so I think that's a
little bit you know the question to you
whether you have the you know the right
data set and you can develop the right
analysis and complete it during the
time of this program we hope that you do
if it's not you know I think you can
continue working on your project even
after the this program ends we will
obviously share with you all the data if
you want to close your account or if you
would like to keep using their account
you know there are ways to transfer that
data to a research account the interface
with R and Python and Java and sequel so
we will show you how to translate the
analysis that you have done on our
platform to R for some of the analysis
if you want to do that analysis in R the
processing for example does not make a
lot of sense just because of the size of
the data and pipeline intensity on the
computational side you typically would
use a server to doing something like
that so if you have access to that
server it's probably something that you
can match right so you can find the
methods that were used in the analysis
that you did here and map it over to
some other environment where you would
like to work for some of the
post-processing steps right so once
you've generated a table let's say how
do you analyze that data with R or
Python and whether you can organize your
data in some kind of a database so that
you can apply sequel right for searching
maybe for the right types of datasets
etc so we'll touch on that in some
general terms this program is not
focused on helping you learn how to code
or use databases we will more apply
those skills from a conceptual
standpoint because I think there's a lot
of user-friendly tools that make this
possible in a short timeframe right for
the longer timeframe we can actually
discuss that and point you to the right
resources about making payments again
maybe maybe you could help Jamila to
finalize her registration so again if
anyone of you need some help with
completing the registration I know it
could be a little bit complicated
because we take the time to review each
submission please email deep shown
directly
or she should be available on chats in
fact I'm just going to share that with
you really quickly so the process of
registration is going to start from this
page which is a forum where you register
right here
and once you submit this you will get an
email notification on how to register on
the educational portal that we have
which is where you would complete that
registration but be sure we'll be able
to answer your questions there on chat
now and take your details if you need
more information databases yes excellent
question let me point you to actually a
collection of different resources that
we have prepared partly for this program
but in general as well so this is in a
blog post that Mohit Mazumdar prepared
just recently right here it has a
collection of different resources and
databases that you can start navigating
thank you Lisa and okay yes so here you
can see a whole collection of different
either visual and educational resources
that you can learn about some of the
viruses that we'll discuss you will find
here NCBI and different resources and
what kinds of data you can find there
NCBI virus for example is a dedicated
resource where you can find all of this
a resource where you can register for
free jazz aid which was originally
designed for influenza research but you
can actually find a lot more there
including coded 19 and other types of
viral pandemics or epidemics where do
you find some gene expression data sets
on NCBI each year VIPRE is a great
resource
originally again designed for influenza
research database but now a lot of
different virus tools are available
there our platform obviously and some of
the different sections that we discussed
here and how to use those and then also
some of the visualization data where you
can also download data for example next
string okay
another question we expect to work on
our project further does that include
any payment so after the program is
going to complete is going to be over at
the end of June you will be able to make
a decision right if you want to continue
and work on the platform you are welcome
to get a research license if you you
know would like to continue working on
it in terms of for example writing your
publication or you know visualizing data
you might not need the platform so you
know feel free to decide for yourself
exactly how you want to manage that just
to give you a sense of the platform and
and what would be available after this
program is over we do have research
licenses or educational licenses if
you're still learning
we do offer support for all of that as
well
but we will also have some other
programs designed specifically for those
interested in research so Mohit maybe
you can share some of those links for
the upcoming programs if you have that
where you know it's not sessions like
this informational sessions it's more
sessions dedicated to analysis and
discussion of analysis results
thank you
okay so again thank you everyone for
joining today this session was recorded
and we will post the recording online if
you would like to see that recording we
will email it to you but also it will be
on our channel on our YouTube channel so
please subscribe to the YouTube channel
and and and see this recording and some
of the other sorry some of the other
previous workshops that we did as well
as some of the other programs just to
get a sense of what that work how that
works how can I get a mentor to start a
specific project so depends on what kind
of mentor are you looking for
I'd be happy to communicate with you
directly if you want so please send an
email to BB Shah who handles those kinds
of questions and and we can take it from
there because we need to learn more
about your project and your interest so
that we can match you with the right
person
alright great um thank you everyone
again for joining we would be again
meeting on Monday for those of you that
have already registered and looking
forward to start learning about you and
your interests as well as you submit
your forms if you have not done any
violent chromatics that's not that does
not mean that you cannot join this
program or some of the other programs
that we have and we welcome you to start
by going through our introduction to
bioinformatics course where you can
learn about the impact on bio
informatics is having on life sciences
all right great thank you rare seized
and looking forward to seeing you as
well
take care everyone and have a great
weekend
Thank You Chandrani and Martin see you
guys on Monday